So today we're going to be talking about
artificial rhythms the merger of Music
programming machine learning I tried to
come up with a catchy title and that was
the best one that I could come up with I
did not ask chat GPT or anyone else for
it by the way um I come up with it
myself um okay so the agenda for today
I'm going to give you a little bit of
background about music and um then I'm
going to tell you about music uh so I'm
going to give you the origins of it I'm
going to tell you about it then I'm
going to give you some tools that you
can use uh for music generation and a
lot of cool things uh about music then
I'm going to tell you what's new then
we're going to do a demo the recap was
supposed to be in a second line but it
might be a demo recap so we don't know
um okay so allow me to introduce myself
my name is Ramon um I'm originally from
the Dominican Republic I lived in the US
for about 10 years then I moved to
Australia um I moved right before the
bush fires in 2019 so I like to say to
people that I had a very warm welcome to
Australia and um from there I moved to
London now I live over there um it's an
amazing place I'm really liking it I've
been there for four months and I got
there in right in the middle of the
summer so for the two weeks of sun that
they get so it was fantastic um all
right so I have a little bit about my
background I have worked as a researcher
in industry and Academia I worked for a
company that does Consumer Behavior
based in Kansas City after that I went
uh to work for a think tank in
Washington DC lofted became an educator
and contined doing research while I was
in Australia um I developed a data
science boot camp there I worked as a
researcher at the intersection of
machine learning and uh management
sciences that was a that was a very very
fun uh couple of years of my life uh and
I'm still having a lot of fun I worked
uh as a freelancer for the last year and
now I join Seldon Seldon does machine
learning infrastructure for the last end
of the machine learning life cycle think
about it whenever you have your model
ready to go and you want to deploy it
somewhere not only do you want to deploy
it but you also want to monitor it and
also you want to explain the predictions
that your model is making so that's what
we do uh we specialize in uh complex use
case such as uh when you need to build
pipelines that have the input of a
machine learning model becomes or the
output of a machine learning model
becomes the input to another or you want
to do ab testing uh or you want to do
Canary deployments or Shadow deployment
if you don't know what those words uh
mean it doesn't matter you can deploy
your motors with us and it's quite cool
um all right so let's get
started um so this is my point of view
on the landscape today of Music
programming and machine learning those
circles they can probably be in
different places and they might not be
intersecting as uh narrowly or as wide
as they are here but it's my point of
view it's my talk um so hopefully I can
amuse you a little bit um so then let's
jump into the music part but without
machine learning for a second before so
that I so that we can get an intuition
as to what um what is that intersection
that we talked about a second ago about
between music programming and machine
learning so before we get started we
need to go back and we need to go way
back and the only reason I wanted to add
this slide here is because I really like
Vox and all this um uh really amazing
news outlets and uh uh media companies
and they always start with a slide that
says let's go back so I wanted to do it
too and and I said well but how far back
so I just found a picture of a cave and
I said well this is far enough uh but
actually it's it's not that far off from
real from reality the first time the
first instance where we found uh an
example of music was 40 just about
40,000 years ago um at a cave in Germany
uh and they found a flute and they
understood that people were using it to
create specific sounds um which is quite
cool this flute is still available in
some sort of Museum that I don't know
where it's at uh then you know we came
to Mozart and or sorry Boven uh and then
that became quite a
um interesting moment in time because
music became something more of a um
we're engaging with this we're having a
great time we're um playing some
instruments and and and that's it and
then you know we have a good time but
then now it's like oh this is something
that we engaged in and we go and seek it
I believe he was one of the first people
that gave uh one of the widest concerts
um or one of the most attended concerts
ever in about 1700s I think it was but
don't quote me on any of those days or
any of that stuff all I want to really
do is to show you that um the pivotal
point of music was when we were able to
start putting music uh into paper and
adding notes cuz now we can actually
take that uh maybe not just yet but now
we can take what's in our heads where we
can play after we practice it a lot and
put it somewhere where somebody else can
copy it somebody else can use it and
that uh hold that thought there but
really all that stuff is just so that I
could show you the transition that we
have gone uh that we have gone through
and now we're um and then you come to
the early 1900s and you get one of the
most spectacular uh pieces of music ever
created and this is one of my fa
favorite sounds one of the best things
I've ever heard in my entire life um so
I'm going to play it for you um just
because it's a lot of fun this guy is
called uh Billy boy Paxton and he's one
of the best musicians one of my favorite
genres is um Bluegrass banjo and then so
we went all the way from making sounds
with flutes to uh in the early 1900s
making sounds that would sound like
this
[Music]
e
you would agree that that's pretty
impressive right and that's not even the
end of it so I really I highly recommend
that you go and see it because then he
starts singing and he gets very like ah
the emotions hit you uh but the point I
show you that is because I want to
create a distinction there I just told
you that a people to point in music was
when we were able to put music into
paper and then take it in but at this
point in time in early 1900s the people
that initiated this movement they
weren't able to put things into pen and
paper uh because they were at that time
uh they were still in slavery or they
were part in um
or they were not able to speak freely
they were not able to do things but we
still managed to capture those things
and now in today's day and age all of
those the things that we were able to
capture the things that we were not able
to capture the things that are uh
written down in piece of paper all of
those can be combined and can be used to
tr to create transformative music with a
combination of programming and uh
machine learning and I'm going to show
you how in a little bit but I just
really wanted to play this uh it's
really
nice um all right
so um then other things that we now do
with digital sounds is that you know
there's a lot of DJs and and there's a
lot of people that can play that they
don't have to be skilled at um so okay
so we have the being able being skilled
at playing an instrument being skilled
at programming being skilled at creating
machine learning models that can create
music but you can also be skilled at
clicking things and that's another cool
one uh all right but how does music make
it into computers can anybody tell me
how does music make it into computers
take a guess share with me midi midi yes
what's midi
it's it's a format for interacting
between yes yes okay how do we get to
MIDI Japan right Japan I I've never been
there but I really want to go there uh
okay okay let's let's get some help
you're on the right track yes how do we
get how does mus make it into our
computers what am I doing right now
microphon microphones yes so your voice
is a stream that stream to be able to
become
so let's take it a step back um sound
what is sound what do you what do you
guys think is
sound W waves waves yeah what is what is
that
wave function yes yes it's air pressure
so sound is air pressure when I'm
talking there's like little waves
imagine little waves coming out of my
mouth so those waves can be translated
via a mathematical function
and be put into a microphone and then it
becomes digital audio the digital audio
becomes uh a string of numbers and I'm
going to show you exactly
how so there's a sound it's coming
through somewhere it's coming out of
somewhere and then sound we just
mentioned the sound equals pressure so
imagine we have two axis and don't worry
there's not going to be any math here uh
and then on one axis we have amplitude
on the other axis we have time in the
middle of that amplitude we're going to
have something uh that is called a that
that's going to be the Baseline so it's
going to be zero um the top level is
going to be a one the lower level is
going to be a minus one both of those
two to make a super confusion are called
Max loudness um and then we're going to
start recording little notes in each one
of those and each one of those is going
to have a little number and then all of
those numbers at the end of it we're
going to call it a frequency that
frequency that frequency is going to be
the amount of notes taken at a specific
second in time or a milliseconds and so
so the wider it is the more seconds we
have or the more milliseconds we have
the shorter it is the more compressed
the information is but that doesn't
really makes sense yet does it so let's
think about it in different ways so now
we have an array of numbers if I want to
compress that array of numbers and make
it so remember I'm talking right now my
voice is being passed through the
microphone it's becoming a digital sound
that you can hear through the through
the speakers but I am speaking at a
particular rate and
then um it's getting transform via that
mathematical function and so on and I
creating an array of numbers that array
of numbers has something called or can
be divided by something called Hertz and
this is the frequency that we can hear
so when we divide a particular sampling
rate via the array of numbers that make
up my voice and the sound of my voice we
get
minutes or we get seconds seconds of me
speaking seconds of a song an instrument
playing minutes of a song usually songs
are between anywhere between 2.45
minutes uh and I don't know 5 minutes 7
minutes and so on so that sound and I
don't want to take it uh further than
that because
that's the right level of intuition for
the rest of the rest of the talk so
that's audio and digital representation
so what are Sound audio why are Sound
audio and music important uh well it
allows us to exess to communicate with
other
people uh and also uh Andrew hubman says
it uh so I think that's important he
said that the he pointed out in one of
his recent who here knows Andrew hu
hubman two people my God my joke failed
there uh or my my moment to shine there
faed well Andrew huberman is a scientist
from uh based in Stanford he's a
professor there and he also has this
amazing podcast on how to make science
accessible to people there was a
fantastic podcast on how music can help
with many different things so um um I
remember my flat M she had a really bad
breakup and she was listening to this
depressing Adele songs every single day
and I'm like that cannot help it can't
help but it just so happens that it does
um when you are
depressed when you are depressed if you
listen to 15 minutes of sad music it
allows you to cope with a pain uh they
didn't say anything in the paper about
longer than 15 minutes so I think she
overdid it uh but um gosh if she's
watching this or if she watches this
later on uh but anyways there are
scientific papers that actually say
music has um beneficial effects for
health and learning and different things
so that's one of the reasons why music
is important the other reason uh is it's
a huge industry the market I think is
over I don't know how many billions you
can add some cereal to it and there's a
lot of there's a lot of money moving
imagine the pandemic none of us could go
out and enjoy a meal at a restaurant but
all of us could go to Spotify and listen
to a song or go to YouTube and watch a
video of our favorite artist performing
a capella or something
similar um and also
um I had a point on this L and I forgot
it uh but it was it's is an artistic
expression uh and that was the point of
it uh I like Homer um okay so sued in
still we still have the music let's go
back into the music programming and
machine learning Paradigm so what about
programming what what's up with the uh
with programming well all of these tools
that we use to listen to music to record
music to enhance music to perform life
all of them are written in different
programming languages uh a very very
popular one for the music industry to
create uh plugins and the like is C++ um
C but also python has come into the um
into the field and actually quite strong
there's a few libraries that are
unbelievable one of my favorite ones is
pedalo by Spotify it allows you to
reading music um add some incredible
effects to it and then export music to
different or save music in different
formats I have a demo uh where I'm going
to uh walk you through pedal Bo and
actually at the end of today we're going
to um at the end of the talk we're going
to see a demo on how to create
microservices with one a model that
generates music from descriptions two a
model that adds effects to your
music um then there's piie audio torch
audio basic pitch creates media
representations um then librosa is
another incredible library in Python
that I really highly recommend it to add
effects to music and do a lot of cool
stuff um in Sound
Processing uh
then um also there's an amazing example
uh so this is something that blew my
mind um I never thought that it was
possible to see live coding of music and
then this guy just nailed it um let me
see if I can actually get this one to
play maybe not
I might not be able to but let me
see nope I'll leave it there for all of
you to no it's such a good example I
have to
play uh let's see if I can get the name
very quickly Pyon uh programming music
for performance life
coding
projects or anything um by default it
will
just
okay so this
guy is typing and assist typing um I
add of sit behind
[Music]
everything uh and we'll add some per
some drums or something just sort of
carry the whole
[Music]
thing uh let's add some qus behind
it so the fact that he's adding this
stuff live as he is
coding so he's
manipulating sound waves in the
background and then adding stuff to the
song I I mean think about a DJ playing
and and moving stuff um and whatnot this
guy is doing kind of the same thing but
writing code at the same time so that's
some of the cool things that python has
come up with sadly Fox dot um I think it
has been inactive for a little bit for
about three four years uh but it's a
really cool tool that if you ever if
you're ever curious about what to do
with music uh I highly encourage you to
test it all right so we talked about
programming music so what about the last
bubble and I made it bigger here but it
didn't have to become a little bit
bigger it could be smaller and but it
doesn't matter let's talk about machine
learning so um who here has some
experience with machine
learning okay hell all right so I'm glad
I didn't put any slides of machine
learning here uh and this is all I did
so this is your for those of of you who
don't you have a pile of things you put
a bunch of data you tell it what the
label is and then you let it do its
thing so that's machine learning that's
as far as I'm going to go because
there's a bunch of experts here that you
can ask after the talk um so then but
what is why is machine learning
important uh better decision making I
put a star over there because better is
very questionable um depending on your
use case faster decision making we can
agree on that one whether it's good or
bad that's a different uh that's a
different thing content creation which
we're going to see today automation
personalize experiences privacy
protection and Innovation so those are
cool things that we can all agree that
machine learning provides us with today
um so so what's new what what's what's
the thing that we're talking about um
well there's amazing things that we can
do with machine learning and one of them
is adding effects to songs I'm going to
give so this one does
play think about being able to create a
model that specifically adds the effects
you want to a song with
very minimal tweaking so this guy was
breaking his fingers trying to type at
the same time uh as the song was coming
up and then this other guy just created
a motel and said well this is going to
do it for me quite
cool so let me give you an
[Music]
example
so that's quite impressive and the fact
that this was done with a motel that was
trained I think very quickly um it
really it really does bring up the point
of well what else can we do with machine
learning what else what is this out
there um what's possible and that's all
for some that's what I'm hoping I can
show you
here
so this is another one
uh think about now we talked about
adding effects to music think about
being able to um say you wanted to go to
you were one of the people that wanted
to go to Taylor to see Taylor Swift and
you were not able to get your hands in a
uh in one of the tickets and you wanted
to you really wanted to listen to a song
that was a capella by her and then you
couldn't do it well kind of you can kind
of do it now say you have
this
[Music]
and then say you could separate it with
h machine
learning you can separate the um just
the sound and then the thing that you
were hoping to see a capella I mean if
this doesn't evoke the same emotion on
you gosh we need to send you to Andrew
hubman
so here's the Acappella
version got feel I don't know
why
so every
[Music]
godamn pretty impressive isn't
it pretty impressive that we can do that
with a machine learning model and we can
combine that with different things now
there also there's also other tools
called um other models that are
completely generating music from
descriptions this is U refusion is kind
of like a combination of all of these
ones but I'm going to I'm going to take
you to the next level step by
step you don't really understand what
this person is saying but but you know
it Rhymes so it sounds
cool it doesn't make any sense
whatsoever but it's
cool this is what I thought when I first
came to the US in 2010 and I was I I
landed in Oklahoma I didn't speak that
much English and let me tell you
everything just sounded like nonsense to
me um and not because anything bad is
because the English that you hear a
little bit in school is kind of quite
perfect and then you get to Oklahoma and
everybody has a dip in their mouth and
you're like oh no no no I'm too focused
on what's Happening Here with like as
supposed to what's coming out of your
mouth so anyways there's other then the
next level is these three particular
models that really broke the industry
this year of at the intersection of
machine learning and um and music and
one of them is called music gen it came
out of Facebook the other one is called
musicm refusion is the one that I just
showed you a second ago and
musei um is another one that came out uh
quite some time ago well quite some time
in the AI industry is probably about a
year ago so let me play you a couple of
sounds and and you be the George wish
one is
[Applause]
best
a grand orchestral arrangement with
thunderous percussion epic brass fan
fairs and soaring strings creating a
cinematic atmosphere fit for the heroic
battle quite
nice
nonsense good try so there's a lot of
stuff happening let me play one more um
okay so this is the original the source
of the melody because one of the things
that you can do you can generate them
with text but you can also do
conditional on some sort of music so say
for example you have a song and then you
wanted to extend it with a description
you wanted to describe something that
you really like and you wanted to use
something that you really like say
Taylor S or anything
[Music]
else so this is one song and then here's
the music gen example '90s so we took
that song that kind of like hip-hop rap
and then we added the description '90s
rock song with electric guitar and heavy
drums he did his
best well that's quite
[Music]
nice so it's it's a trial and error it's
kind of like asking uh Chad gbt hey what
should I do uh for the weekend and then
he comes with a bunch of stuff that
doesn't exist in your city because it
doesn't have it doesn't know that in
which city you're at um and it's kind of
this one like you have to really find
tuna you have to um or not necessarily F
tuna but you have to play with these
prompts to get something that comes out
that you really really like um and then
another one that is incredible is
cloning imagine that so we went from
adding audio effects to separating songs
and creating this Acappella version to
generating songs from plain descriptions
now imagine you can take the voice of
your favorite artist and put put it
somewhere um and and how cool would that
be that you can just come up with
nonsense words and then have Drake sing
it it's not like it
[Music]
has so that is that sounds pretty much
like Drake right and that is not him
singing um here's another
one
[Music]
pretty impressive now um one more thing
um that you can also do uh or that you
can also find let me
see you can
go as well and not necessarily take
artist not take a sound that was
generated by someone but you can also
create specific sounds say for example
so when you think about the music
industry you might be only thinking
about artists uh but also videos taking
music uh podcasts might have a
soundtrack behind it or um games video
games have music in them and some of
this music is copyright music some of
this music is created by someone
specifically for that for the purpose of
that game imagine that now I don't want
to take the job away from a lot of
artists but damn it if you can just
describe it how cool is that um so
listen to uh let me play this one
that sounds like it could be I don't
know in a cinematic scene going into
somewhere
uh that could be part of a
game but it doesn't have to be so we're
now to the point that music might be
indistinguishable from the real thing to
some to some degree let me see if I'm
still
uh text to
song Oh I created I actually created a
um a song for today with Peta uh in it
so
[Music]
so I said this is my first time in P I
had a lot of free food and free coffee I
hope there's more stuff like that next
year or something like that is what I
said so U so I'm glad I made you laugh
on that one that's the whole point of
this thing you might not remember the
whole talk but if you laugh at Le at
least it was a good time um okay so what
are the tools that we can use um so
Transformers pyo and diffusers they're
um kind of like taking over right now on
Music Creation uh and then we're going
to see a couple of these tools here in a
second uh but those are pretty much the
ones that are taken over um so what's
next uh by the way opinion alert uh so
it is is it okay so some of the
questions that we might ask ourselves
when we think about music generation art
um is it okay to use the voice of an
artist to train a motto that's going to
become more and more prevalent there are
artists that are quite okay with it and
they want to take a fee one example is
Grimes um she has a I think she calls it
the AI twin don't quote me on that one
um but she's okay with it and taking
royalty fees from people using her voice
to generate music but she's not uh she's
not the majority of people so if so what
about the royalty Feast should we if a
person is making money out of a song
that was created from uh using a similar
voice to a particular artist should that
artist get some royalty fees from that
so for
debate um Can the artist can an artist
say uh Hey delete my voice or delete my
uh delete me from your data set is that
possible um I believe there was a there
was a paper a couple of months ago that
where with specific instructions to a
model you can always make it so that it
doesn't produce so that it doesn't use a
particular artist if the artist was in
the data set so maybe methods like that
are more uh realistic than asking a
company that spend a million dollars
training a modo to retrain it because
you don't want to be in it or because
they didn't ask
you uh and then also is there some sort
of middle ground in between like can we
have this amazing AI music and AI
generated things and can we also uh have
artists be happy about it can they use
this to make music maybe faster maybe
better maybe I don't know more creative
and so
on okay so time for a demo
uh this might be a little bit too
dark uh
so okay there you
go all right so um I have a couple of
things that um I created the other day
for a workshop on uh building machine
learning microservices
and one of the the the tool that I ended
up creating or one of the demos there's
about three or four demos and you can
find the talk I I believe it's going to
be posted quite soon it was at mlops
World um but I'm going to show you the
uh I'm going to show the
app
radio and then we're going to walk
through uh the example uh a couple of
examples
I believe I have about is that our 45 I
have about 10 minutes or so so we got
time to see it in
action so this is the app we're going to
take a description of a song we can
tweak the number of tokens I'm going to
explain what that is here in a second um
we have a couple of parameters that we
can pass we're going to get the song in
here and then we're going to be able to
visualize the song one thing is the
waveform you saw my awesome hand drawing
earlier of a waveform um then we're
going to see How do machine how does a
machine learning model understand sound
because that's that's one thing that we
haven't mentioned I'm going to mention
it here in a second U then we're going
to pass it through an a audio effect um
not model but artifact or object that is
also um uh served and then lastly we're
going to pass it through we're going to
create a meded representation uh for
it okay so uh back
here so we have I mentioned uh the motel
that we were comparing a little bit ago
was uh music gen and music gen we
compare music gen with music LM from
Google Music gen is from meta they um
contributed to the Transformers Library
by Hogan face they contributed a class
that can be used to call that model or
different variations of that model and
that's called uh music gen for
conditional
generation if you have
um
who here has done um any kind of deep
learning whatsoever a little bit okay we
have a few people who here has used the
Transformers
Library okay let's explain uh for a
second what's happening here so here I
have a uh the description of a song and
it is classic music with fast tempo
violin sounds and a guitar solo ending
uh what is happening here we have
usually when you have a model um that is
similar to a language model of sorts or
in particular a Transformer you're going
to have a step that is called a
tokenizer or a step that takes in uh
your description or your input and
generates a representation of it inside
the model that representation is going
to be used to do some resampling uh and
to do some calculations and to do some
stuff and then generate the thing that
you want those representations in this
instance are going to be um something
called um an embedding or input IDs and
then those input IDs map to certain
values inside the networ work of the
model then there's the other piece of
Transformers which is called attention
so what is this attention
thing um if you think about a um a
sentence I really like um coffee and
bagels if I take out the word like and I
just say I really coffee and bagels you
might not be able to understand so in
the model in the way in which he trained
it's trained to detect what things you
got to pay attention in that sentence
when it once it gets split into the
components that it needs to be split by
so it's going to know that okay really
like is going to be part of it it adds
some context it adds some meaning to it
and I am I'm doing a lot of hand waving
here but I want you to get an intuition
not necessarily become a deep learning
expert in this next five minutes that we
have together so I had a
description um and then the other thing
is we talked about the sampling rate so
we have a sampling rate that is
important for the generation of our
model or at least to explore the output
of it remember that we have little
points that represent a piece of sound a
piece of vibration and when we compress
all of those we get something called
amplitude that amplitude or becomes or
that compression of all those numbers
become a second or however we divide it
is going to become hopefully a
second um so then we have the motel we
pass in the inputs if you've never seen
this uh two stars here that means unpack
the dictionary so take every key value
pair and put it as a parameter similar
to this one here so then we have do
sampling so it's going to be sampling
from a distribution using those IDs the
the representation of our um description
then the guidance scale um the higher
the number the closer it matches your
description the lower the number the
more creative it gets but the less it
matches your description the maximum
amount of tokens control the um the
length of your song so if a token in a
word is every piece sorry if a token in
a sentence is every p is every word in
that sentence a token in sound is going
to be once it once it becomes an image
imagine we chop an image and every
single piece of that image that little
those little patches that's going to
become a token and that's that is the
representation that our model is seeing
inside so when we add more tokens we
might be adding different patches inside
an image but we might not be adding a
complete second so one what I'm trying
to say with this is one token doesn't
map to one second many tokens do so now
we created a song and um we can see the
shape of that song it has about
22280 values that are going to be
divided by our sampling rate and it's
going to give us the second that that
song um is going to last so now this is
what we
[Music]
created
quite nice quite nice what if we wanted
to add some effect to it I mentioned the
library librosa earlier and there's a
really nice Effect called um hpss which
is the harmonic uh something something
something from uh from mathematics and
it distorts the sound and it adds some
effect to it and let's see what that
what that sounds
like nonsense
what about the other one so there's two
it gives you two um two things to use
and one is the harmonic um let's see
they're right here uh it automates the
waveline uh harmonic and percussive
components of an audio um sample and
then so here's the harmonic one it
should sound
[Music]
[Applause]
nicer so that those sound nicer than
this
kind of like
more not in a room kind of okay um here
we have pedor I mentioned that this is
another the other library in Python that
is quite nice to add effect for adding
effects to a song um I never thought I
was going to play Toxic by Britney at a
conference but I am going
[Music]
to let's add some effect to it we cannot
erase her voice uh and there's nothing
wrong with her voice
uh but we can but we can add some effect
to it uh let's see what that sounds like
I am not a music expert but I know that
the Reverb has a room size so imagine if
he wanted to make a song sound a little
bit more like his life you will add a
little bit of room effect maybe or you
would add something you add some sort of
delay because nobody can sing oneto one
perfectly a capella or um at a concert
that they can when they are recording in
a studio there's a lot of things that
happen in both of
those again I'm not an expert in any of
these things so uh let's see what it
sounds
[Music]
[Applause]
like kind of sounds a little bit louder
like a little bit more in a room you can
play with this the idea is that you can
play with this parameters and create
something very very cool um and then
also
I I am Latino I have to play something
uh Latin so I have one here called and I
know we're coming out of time so uh
Celia ju C
let's see if this sounds better than
toxic I know it will but you
[Music]
know so this is Cia Cruz from Cuba
amazing salsa and um uh Samba singer um
and she's just fantastic so let's see
what that sounds like when we pass it
through our Distortion um so our effects
[Applause]
Creator so it sounds a little bit I
don't know like it's in a big room and
so on but now to the to the point of
this Stu we can save that we can do a
bunch of stuff um I mentioned earlier
that you can pass one of these songs
that we created and then you can have it
as the uh condition on upon your
description so the description that we
created earlier we can attach this new
sample to it I'm not going to do it in
the interest of time because I know
we're running out of time um but I want
to show you how would you serve this
Motel so I already have the app open
running but none of these components is
is connected to a model the reason why I
I said microservices is because we have
want to have a separation of concerns we
might want to have our app be developed
by the front end developers who know
about that stuff we might want the back
end to be developed by the backend
developers who know about that stuff and
then we want ourselves the machine
learning Engineers the data scientists
the data professionals to focus on the
motel and potentially making it useful
creating a microsof service out of it
why I like to think um the your Motel
the motel that you create is only as
useful as the value that it adds to your
users so with that in mind let's create
a quick service and we're going to use
one of the tools that my company we
develop is called ml server is an open
source tool um a wrapper around fast API
and a bunch of other tools that allows
you to serve asynchronously uh many
models and one of the cool things that
it does is that it also allows you to do
batch uh batch prediction adaptive
batching you can set up the um many you
can specify many things that you want
your server um to to do before you put
your server up and running and how do
you do this well we have a couple of
things for ML server the main class um
the server the settings the model
settings and the model we have the
Transformer model that we um added a
second ago and then we have a couple of
other things like the asyn Kyo um typing
uh the Asing Kayo and the uh type from
the typing module then we're going to
create a class this is the most
important piece or one of the most
important pieces you create a class and
if you have never seen this recipe if
you are new to serving models there's a
bit of a recipe for serving models one
of the things you want to do two things
when you serve a model you want to load
it you want to keep the weights there or
you want to keep your artifact loaded
and you don't want to have to reload it
every time you're going to make a
prediction and then the second thing
that you want to do is you want to have
a predict function when something comes
in and output goes out that step is
called
inference so we have our uh two classes
here the processor and the conditional
generation we add them to the class and
then we have the inputs here we pass it
through the generator function and we
return a nonp array we need to know the
sampling rate which is why we have three
sample rates down here now we're
connecting the
components so um we add that to our file
so notice that here I'm using a Jupiter
notebook um magic where I created a file
in a particular folder and then in here
I added an a to attach a pen that this
piece to that file and then lastly we
need the function that is going to run
our server we have the settings here I
have debug true but I can also say hey
if I'm using the a particular Port I can
say
HTTP uh port and say actually um serve
this thing in 7070 and so
on um you can also it it also accepts
grpc but that's beyond um here right
beyond our time together um lastly you
passing those settings here you tell you
give your model a particular name this
is going to be part of the URL that
you're going to give your frontend
developers hey this is where my model is
served that this is the URL that you're
going to use to send requests to these
are the specifications of our
model then we pass in uh the
implementation which is the name of the
class and then we pass it through our
server to start if you've ever done a
synchronous pring um as Kayo will start
an event Loop and then it will run until
completion when things come in
um okay so now we have it now we can
start our second server so we have one
for the front end and then we're going
to have one for
um uh for our
model I am also at typing and speaking
at the same time if you didn't notice um
so then we call our program our M
service uh.
py and then that's going to start a
server and if you've ever used Fast API
you're going to notice that this looks
quite similar uh we starting a server
this is the um the uh the route that
we're going to use and then this is the
motto being loaded there so if we come
back up here and we describe I describe
something here uh a fast bachata with
violin sounds and a few notes from a
saxophone so I'm going to say create
create the music and then it's going to
start loading as you can see here it
says 4.6 and it's counting the seconds
so this request is being sent to my
server over here which ideally of course
right now I'm developing locally but
later on this is going to be sitting on
a server in AWS gcp or somewhere else
and then someone from your team is going
to send a request to it and it's going
to attach that logic to your front end
so now you're going to make your Motel
useful notice that down here that was
successful uh that request so let's see
the song that we
created that was quite nice and then if
we want to visualize the the wave form
of that and see what does my audio look
like then we can visualize it with
another function and you might be
wondering where the heck is this
function on remote whereas in some of
the files that I created in the year um
so those two functions are in a
directory called SRC plotting and they
are using matplot lip so it's taken in
the the waveform and it's create Sor
it's looking at the latest file that I
created and then it's passing it in as a
waveform and it's creating a MPL L
figure that's beyond the scope of this
um I wanted to show you the microservice
aspect of this and then the other one is
the spectrogram I mentioned how does a
machine learning model uh understand
what is happening understand a piece of
audio well that piece of audio becomes a
spectrogram and it becomes an image once
we have that image we can chop it into
pieces and those pieces becomes become
the
tokens and then lastly we want to add
some effect to it but I haven't served
that model yet and that's the last piece
of this uh of this whole
Workshop so um I have here
a um I have here some requests that I
can send to my motto but I'm going to
skip them in the interest of time and
I'm going to create the last piece of
the puzle the um not the visualizations
but the audio effect so safe for example
um earlier I walked through a couple of
things from pedalo and we talked about
delay pitch and Reverb and so on so if
we wanted to create a file the other way
to create this is by creating a py file
with only the Modo specification so
notice here that I am only adding a um
this files over here my imports that I
need and then I'm adding the class that
is going to have my pedal War uh effects
in the first one I am adding a a default
oneand that I want my model to always
take in so every song that comes through
you're going to add this effect and then
for the other ones I'm going to add a
little bit more um just in case because
this one the idea is that we could
create more parameters and pass it
through our function and then tell our
developers in the front end hey these
are the things that you can tweak these
are the things that you can allow our
users to
tweak so we are adding this to our um
server um to our that py file and then
we need two more files to save uh so the
first way I show you how to serve ml
server was via python file the second
way is via the command line this is the
second way so you have a name I'm going
to call it novice DJ because I'm nowhere
near an expert um I have the name of the
file that I just created audio mixer and
then I have the name of the class that
is the implementation then we have
different ports here so that it doesn't
clash with the one that we have running
right now so if I add these two to the
same directory I'm going to show you
what the directory looks like I have a a
directory called servers and in this one
I have one called pedal board I have
three files that I just created the
audiomixer py the Moto Das settings.
Json and the settings. Json that you see
here that you see here and that you see
here so there's about 25 lines of code
and if you become very frugal you can
actually make a less than that um okay
so we created those how do we serve
it last
okay so I'm going to do ml server start
and then I'm going to go directly to
that directory that I was in servers
pedal war and then I don't need to point
to a single file I only need to point to
the directory that my Moto is at then I
hit that and then the same server start
and notice that it already loaded my
Moto novice DJ and now we can come up
here and we can add some effect to the
song that we created so uh for the
record let me play it again uh the one
oh this reloaded I'm going to create
that song
again with the same parameters same um
uh same
description let's see what it came up
with this
[Music]
time not quite great uh but the first
one the first one was way better we can
visualize the other two things that we
have um there was an error
there uh okay doesn't matter now let's
update that
song okay so here's the the updated
[Music]
version Oh that was a very awful note to
end on actually so you know what uh
before we leave because this is the
ending before we leave I want to leave
you on a good note P intended on that
one uh because that one was
awful that was just awful
so before we go this is the last one
that I'll show
you actually let's play this
one okay so that's the last note and
then one last message that I have
because I wanted to end it in a good
note um okay key takeaway uh if you want
to get started with or Advance your
skills in programming and other data
related you know insert your favorite
boss we here um it doesn't have to be
with financial data it doesn't have to
be with house prices data or other
common use cases pick your favorite song
and tweak it update it enhance it and
whatever you do do not sell it without
checking the copyright laws attached to
it first thank you very much everyone
[Applause]